à Tel Aviv samedi soir des dizaines de
milliers d'Israéliens sont venus crier
leur colère
ils manifeste contre la réforme
judiciaire du Premier ministre Benyamin
Netanyahou un symbole de la grande
contre son nouveau gouvernement décrit
comme étant le plus à droite de
l'histoire du pays
réduit en novembre il a pris la tête
d'une coalition formée de partie
d'extrême droite et ultra orthodoxe dont
certains ont des positions par exemple
antipalestinienne des lacermentations de
ce nouveau gouvernement l'ambassadrice
d'Israël en France annonce sa démission
Yaël German se dit incapable de
continuer à représenter des politiques
si différentes des siennes
son homologue au Canada Rena Hoffman
entré en poste il y a un peu plus d'un
an annonçons départ lui aussi avec la
transition vers un nouveau gouvernement
et le changement de politique en Israël
écrit-il mon intégrité personnelle et
professionnelle m'a amené à demander de
raccourcir mon mandat et de retourner en
Israël cet été il s'est dit que son
orientation politique étant très
différente de celle du gouvernement
actuel qui ne pouvait continuer ses
fonctions Richard Marceau connaît assez
bien ambassadeur sa nomination dit-il
était avant tout politique monsieur
hormone est très proche du Premier
ministre précédent ayant servi avec lui
au parlement israélien la kinéset ce
n'est pas une surprise de voir que qu'il
est inconfortable avec le gouvernement
actuel et qu'il a décidé de poursuivre
la lutte politique en Israël
le prédécesseur de Benyamin Netanyahou
participe d'ailleurs au mouvement de
contestation
Israël d'hier rapide sont venus défendre
sa démocratie au gouvernement là qui est
le premier gouvernement
israélien avec des parties de droite et
des parties religieux ont décidé
de changer les règles du jeu de la
démocratie israélienne la réforme
judiciaire dénoncée permettrait au
Parlement de passer outre une décision
de la Cour suprême c'est véritablement
une un changement une modification
profonde des règles du jeu politique en
Israël et encore une fois on a le droit
de le faire mais à condition que ce soit
large consensus c'est plutôt un bras de
fer qui semble se jouer autant au
Parlement que sur le terrain
diplomatique et dans la rue ici
Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada
Montréal